this episode of gamespot's holiday gift
guide is presented by best buy hello and
welcome to GameSpot's holiday gift guide
2014 i'm jeff cannata so here's your
dilemma you've got a kid in your life
who loves video games but you're
bombarded on all sides by M rated and
teen rated games and you're not sure
what to get them for the holidays we'll
never fear we're here to help we've got
five great games that are great for kids
and sure to bring smiles to the lucky
children who unwrap them this holiday
but before I give you my pics let's see
what some real-life kids think um I wish
my new friend was here right now sonic
bloom is awesome for Christmas I want
sonic boom my favorite video game is
minecraft because I get to play with my
friends build a lot of stuff my favorite
game is Mario Kart this year's mario
kart 8 for Wii U is the first in the
series to be in high definition boy does
it pop do gravity-defying tracks loads
of unlockables and all the popular
Nintendo characters you could want Mario
Kart is a gift for them that can also be
a gift for you i play my laptop with me
Dad yeah he drives a car all the way to
coat like that yes very funny yes love
us Nintendo has done an incredible job
bringing their brawler to a handheld
system for the first time this game has
a ton of content in it and the tried and
true knock them off the ledge fighting
system is cartoonish and tons of fun
gasps too yeah Stan into Jackie my game
on my xbox also Skylanders trap team I
just put the figure on and like it just
gets me a whole new suit I'm like wow
this year brings a new version of
Skylanders complete with a whole new
crop of figures to collect Skylanders
trap team is available for every
conceivable platform and introduces a
bunch
new characters to play and villains to
defeat I always a doctorate is live dad
it led beat him good I blew a stronger
the Avengers spider-man and even the
guardians of the galaxy can now join in
on the fun and hang out on your shelf
with Disney infinity 2 point 0 Marvel
superheroes with new collectible toys
that bring the characters and their
narratives into the game Lego Batman you
again it's really cool how like um I
could like defeat like all the enemies
in the game that's just my kind of style
game this year's latest Lego game is
lego batman three beyond Gotham and it's
a celebration of both Lego and the DC
Universe over a hundred and fifty DC
characters make this adventure feel huge
exciting and worthy of the name now
you're armed with five great suggestions
for children in your life go forth give
gifts thanks for watching gamespot's
Holiday Gift Guide 2014 and have a very
happy holiday